[Music]
foreign
[Music]
still not getting it thank you sure Roy
here has slept with a bunch of different
people in his past but keeley's got her
own romantic and sexual history that
predates Roy and that's not okay
oh he means the opposite
Apple streaming service launched in
November 2019 with a suite of Buzzy high
profile shows including the morning show
and Dickinson since then the company is
offered critically acclaimed series
including the feel good sports comedy
Ted lasso the animated musical series
Central Park and so much more corn
puddin what's that what
are you trying to tell me that you've
never heard of corn pudding
song you just started another song but
which of those series have earned their
spot among the best Apple TV plus
offerings so far we're ranking the best
of the best and assuring that these
shows must have a minimum of 10 reviews
to be included we believe these shows
are the best so let's count down the
best Apple TV Plus shows ranked by
Tomato Meter
[Music]
number 10 servant
a Philadelphia couple is in mourning
after an unspeakable tragedy creates a
rift in their marriage this also opens
the door for a mysterious Force to enter
their home starring Lauren Ambrose Toby
kebbel Rupert Grint Nell tiger free
executive produced by M Night Shyamalan
and created by Tony baskala critics say
those servants slithering mystery often
wanders into dark crowded Corners it's
claustrophobic atmosphere and Powerful
performances build enough tension to
keep viewers hooked
we never left
you mean Philly
the smell
or
sponging off
Rocky
what can you see what can you hear
me
or
he's behind the door
oh
take a deep breath you're in a safe
space here no he's not go back there
who's behind the doors
dirt on their knees for him
there
leading number nine smigadoon
in a parody of 1940s musicals
backpacking couple Melissa and Josh get
trapped in schmidgetoon a magical Town
filled with singing and dancing
townspeople there they learned that they
can't leave without finding true love
which they thought they already had
starring Cecily Strong Keegan Michael
Key Dove Cameron and created by Cinco
Paul and Ken Dario critics say
schmitted's clever inside theater jokes
may not be for everyone but there's no
denying the joy of seeing this talented
Ensemble sing and dance their hearts out
whoa this is uh some little hike well I
thought it'd be good to get away
especially from that heartless Miss
Melissa oh let's not talk about Miss
Melissa you poor thing I mean you must
really be hurting
don't you worry Betsy is gonna make it
all better
would you like that
yes
I would
oh I just love this place the high
school kids call it virginity ruins it's
where they all come to you know picnic
not that I've been here before
he
well if you had been here before it
would have been a long time ago because
it was way back when you were in high
school am I right oh
oh it was the swing I used to swing on
the summer that I turned 14. oh it seems
like that was only yesterday but it
wasn't right
number eight the after party
when a high school reunions after party
ends in a stunning death everyone is a
suspect a detective grills a former
classmates one by one uncovering
potential motives as each tells their
version of the story culminating in the
shocking truth starring Tiffany haddish
Sam Richardson Zoe chow and created by
Phil Lord and Chris Miller critics say
the after party sometimes strains to
keep the Jamboree of yucks going but
it's ambitious melding of genres and
extensive guest lists of actors make for
a worthwhile nightcap Party People Big
Ups to Hill Mountain High we started at
the upper middle and now we're here but
for tonight Mikasa
is
I mean you know how the rest of that
goes wow we gotta live forever
how does this all go so wrong celebrity
humanitarian Xavier was bound dead
tonight his body discovered on the cliff
during an after party for his high
school reunion this is a murder
any one of you could be the murderer and
I want to hear your story the same thing
could happen but you see it in a
different way I want to hear your mind
movie
did you see her hair it looks like she
made out with a tornado it's just Jewish
hair so much volume
number seven Dickinson Emily Dickinson
poet daughter and total Rebel in this
coming-of-age story Emily is determined
to become the world's greatest poet
starring Haley Steinfeld Toby Huss Jane
Krakowski and created by Alina Smith
critics say audacious and aspirational
Dickinson's bold blend of period drama
and Millennial milieu definitely won't
be for all but those looking to break
free from the doldrums of their viewing
life may find some kind of Hope in its
singular vision
so
Emily pay attention to your aunt Lavinia
she's traveled all over the world and
brought back many mystical Secrets yes I
have girls you are about to engage in
something that was used in all the
ancient civilizations Egypt Greece
let me call it
what listening got a fair go talk
thought we were going to relax let's
relax while we don't
for some reason I don't think you're
going to let me do that remember water
is medicine and Truth protects well I'm
definitely feeling a lot better
where do you think you're going we paid
for 17 more minutes in here oh well I
I for us to try the body healer
oh I've heard great things about her
she's very Moon oriented exactly big fan
of that
number six trying
all Nikki and Jason want is a baby but
it's the one thing they can't have so
they decide to adopt with their
Dysfunctional Friends screwball families
and chaotic lives the adoption panel may
not agree they're ready to be parents
starring rafe's ball Esther Smith Imelda
Staunton and created by Andy Walton
critics say Leeds rafe's ball and Esther
Smith make light work of heavy themes in
trying a poignant comedy that is as
hilarious as it is honest about the
realities of infertility
to love sex oh no I've just had a big
dinner and it's one in the morning we
still enjoy having sex with me
absolutely yes as much as you used to
yes wow I've seen the film before so I'm
not on the edge of our seat but it's
still my favorite film of all time kids
we have actually been trying for kids
for a while now
[Music]
with your complications
very unlikely
so what do we do now a small piece of us
dies and we just carry on with
whatever's left all right well as long
as we've got a plan
I think I'm ready to talk about adopting
you've got to be careful with adoption
Mel from the club got a rescue dog
everywhere I don't know what I'm
supposed to do with that information
number five Ted lasso
an American football coach is hired to
manage a British soccer team but what he
lacks in knowledge he makes up for in
optimism determination and biscuits
starring Hannah waddingham Juno Temple
and Jason Sudeikis who developed the
show with Bill Lawrence Brendan hunt and
Joe Kelly critics say warm and Winsome
if not particularly hilarious Ted lasso
fleshes out its promo premise with
unrelenting optimism and a Charming turn
from Jason Sudeikis I don't think
there's anything to talk about I told
Jamie it wasn't gonna happen oh
oh no no I feel awkward I bet
did everybody see me when I stomped off
the patient no no one saw that yeah man
everyone saw that come on
I'm so sorry it's okay Sam all right you
are a leader on this team I want you to
speak your mind
thank you
[Music]
you know my father says every time he
sees you on TV he's very happy that I am
here
that I'm in in safe hands with you
well that means a lot
I appreciate that
you know I still got to make you run a
bunch of laps though around oh I was
hoping you would too all right I'll keep
going thank you yes
very well handled geez
thank you
number four little America this
Anthology series observes the funny
romantic heartfelt inspiring and
surprising stories of immigrants in
America starring siraj Sharma Cheryl and
Fenn and executive produced by Lee
Eisenberg who serves as the showrunner
critics say joyous heartfelt and very
human little America's thoughtful
collection of immigrant Tales is as
inspirational as it is relatable odd tax
after you see the ticket Place only in
America can such a perfect game exist
baseboard hamburgers cheeseburgers bacon
chili cheeseburger everything on top of
everything only in America
[Music]
I'm going to America soon I'm gonna be a
Hollywood star
[Music]
I am looking for instinct
thank you
[Music]
we're trying this is where we will live
you see the rock right you see a rock I
see an opportunity
number three Central Park
Owen and his family live in
unconventional life in New York's
bustling Central Park which Owen manages
now they'll have to fend off a wealthy
Hotel heiress who wants to turn the park
into condos starring Leslie Odom Jr Emmy
raver Lampman Titus Burgess and Josh
gadd who created the show with Lauren
Bouchard and Nora Smith critics say with
warmth wit and a Pitch Perfect Ensemble
Central Park is a joyously hilarious
musical love letter to the Big Apple I
didn't get anything and I'm a terrible
reporter and I've wasted your braces
money um Mom no no what you no it wasn't
me oh really did one of those Hotel
bears break in here something that my
father will pay I just really needed to
have a Toblerone I guess three
toblerones and cashews and everything
else duh I hear this neck attack ugh I
can't believe the big meeting is just a
wedding no offense on you it's fine it's
just the saddest day of my life why is
it the saddest day of your life I can't
marry Zach I just can't
I love Zack but he's from a normal
family mine does some bad things I mean
everyone's family has issues murder the
arms dealing fixing the Oscars got it do
you love him yes that's why I can't
marry him Anya sometimes you gotta just
trust your God and take a chance
number two Mythic Quest
the team behind the biggest multiplayer
video game of all time is tasked with
building worlds molding Heroes and
creating Legends but the most
hard-fought battles don't occur in the
game they happen in the office starring
Charlotte McDowell Danny pootie and Rob
mceleney who created the show with
Charlie Day and Megan Ganz critics say
while it relies too heavily on the
workplace comedy formula Mythic Quest is
nonetheless hilarious and stands out for
exploring the gaming industry with
intelligence thoughtfulness and
sincerity hey Poppy what are you doing
good news I have turned the shovel into
a weapon so now it's a dual purpose this
is something that people are gonna buy
check this out
it's not quite right but I'm close I
just I'm not sure if it's like a
if it should be a debt maybe it's an
uppercut motion yeah no I don't I don't
want the shovel to kill people I just
want it to dig dig do you have any idea
what the TTP on an item like this is
gonna be yeah it's gonna be like a TTP
guys it's time to penis it's the time it
takes for a player to use a new item to
make a penis yes I know what TTP is yeah
David stop man explaining they're not
good at not gonna make iron you give the
public a shovel they did you get my pen
they draw you give them some clay
definitely going to sculptbox
iron would you please tell my assistant
to get into the booth oh I don't tell
women what to do I love them to make
their own choices thank you yeah
absolutely and they're not gonna they're
not gonna turn them into I'm gonna
actually put a limiter on it so they
can't shovel with rules that's really
cool yeah let's put as many rules in the
game as we can that's that's super fun
and before we reveal number one here are
some honorable mentions
For All Mankind
the high stakes lives of NASA astronauts
and their families in a world where the
global Space Race never ended starring
Joel Kinnaman Michael Dorman Sarah Jones
and created by Ronald D Moore Matt
Wolpert and Ben nadivi critics say
though it shoots through the moon and
Falls somewhere in orbit for all
Mankind's impressive vision of History
has the potential for real liftoff if it
leans into the things that set it apart
instead of settling for more of the same
inko go Houston 24 you go for FCC power
up and self-test pushing in the breaker
now
to skis back online
[Music]
wait a minute
tank pressures are rising and I'm I'm
showing turbo pumps startup
get them away from that booster it's
still armed
are you clear of the RCs damn it Tracy
don't over correct I'm trying to regain
control but we're still Tethered to 24.
we're closer I'll let tether you Molly
you do that and you cut your own safety
line who gives a damn save this
[Music]
Dr Brain
brilliant brain scientist C1 suffers a
horrific personal tragedy desperate to
uncover what happened to his family he
conducts brain sinks with the dead to
access their memories for Clues starring
Lee Sun Keon Lee Yu Young Park hee soon
and created by Kim ji-woon critics say
working its way through a heady premise
perhaps a little too ponderously Dr
Brain nevertheless gives viewers plenty
of cerebral Thrills to mull over
foreign
[Music]
foreign
the morning show
an unapologetically candid drama that
looks at the Modern workplace through
the lens of the people who help wake
America up pulling back the curtain on
early morning TV starring Jennifer
Aniston Reese Witherspoon Steve Carell
and created by Michael Ellenberg critics
say though the morning show at times
feels more like a vanity project than
the hard-hitting drama it aspires to be
there is pleasure to be had in watching
Jennifer Aniston and Reese Witherspoon
give it their all
wrong whatever it's easy to get for
people wrong what else it makes it makes
stops for everybody everyone's happy yes
what is death okay you think that's a
good idea no and that's so positive why
do you think all these people are out
here protesting because they think it's
dangerous or whatever do you think it's
dangerous do you even know what's in
coal ash arsenic copper lead Mercury
uranium that is some toxic [ __ ] what
about jobs what do you know how many
jobs have been lost in the last 10 years
I don't know thousands thousands of
[ __ ] families knocked on their asses
and it's just a big wheel that goes
around liberals out sanctions
conservatives remove those sanctions and
they just keep fighting because all they
want to do is hear themselves talk and
they all want to be right and they all
want to win and that's all they care
about and there's a human cost and it's
exhausting
okay okay and finally number one
Acapulco
in 1984 Maximo gallardo's dream comes
true when he gets the job of a lifetime
at Acapulco's hottest Resort Las Colinas
however he soon realizes that working
there will be far more complicated than
he ever imagined starring Enrique
Arizona Damien Alcazar Eugenio Derbez
and created by Austin winsberg Eduardo
Cisneros and Jason Schumann critics say
buoyed by its talented Ensemble and
smart genial humor Acapulco is as
sweetly nostalgic as it is utterly
Charming
oh you go I've decided to tell you my
life story it all starts
this was the deciding moment in my life
for a crooked from the streets of
Acapulco the way to a better life was a
job at Las Colinas the most glamorous
Resort of all
I am the owner of Las Colinas
Welcome to our hotel
[Music]
I can't believe I'm sitting here I can't
believe I'm sitting anywhere my family
just has the one chair
this is where all the action is one
mistake in your career here will be good
luck puppy
so I just started filming until a dog is
that normal here more normal than you
think
Maximo if you want to keep this shop
maybe don't hit on the boss's girlfriend
[Music]
my mother was afraid the resort would
change me but maybe
it would be the other way around
and friends that about does it for us be
sure to stay tuned to the Rotten
Tomatoes channel for more of the
entertainment content you love until
next time I'm your host Naz Perez and
we'll see you back here for more top
tens on the Rotten Tomatoes countdown
[Music]
foreign
[Music]